Thanks for making time, Dev. So just to set context, Verdant Kitchens is our ready-to-cook meal kit brand, we launched in Bangalore eighteen months ago and we're now in four cities.
The problem we have is that we look like every other meal kit startup. Same green packaging, same stock photos of vegetables. We need a brand identity that actually feels premium and modern, because our price point is higher than the competition and right now nothing justifies it visually.
Understood. So the core objective is repositioning Verdant as a premium brand rather than a convenience brand. Is that fair?
Exactly. Premium but approachable. We don't want to feel intimidating or cheffy. The idea is real cooking made effortless, not restaurant theatre.
To add to that, our audience is very specific. It's urban working professionals, twenty eight to forty five, mostly double income households in metros, Bangalore, Mumbai, Delhi NCR and Pune. Household income upwards of eighteen lakhs. They cook two or three times a week, not daily.
Got it, so end customers, direct to consumer. Are we also speaking to any retail or partner audience with this?
Primarily end customers. Retail comes later, let's not scope that in right now.
Right. So on deliverables, from what I'm hearing we're looking at a full brand identity system, logo, colour, typography, packaging direction, and then comprehensive brand guidelines. Plus a new website. Anything on the social side?
Yes, social media branding too. We post daily on Instagram and it's a mess right now, every post looks like a different company. So templates, a visual language, the whole thing.
And the website needs to actually convert. Right now it's a Shopify template. We want something modern and engaging that reflects the new identity.
Understood. So brand identity guidelines, social media branding, and the website. Are we doing any video at this stage, a launch film or explainers?
Not in this phase. Maybe a brand film later once the identity is locked, but let's keep this phase to identity, guidelines, social and web.
Perfect. On messaging, is there a line or a thought that captures what you want people to feel? Even roughly.
Something like real food, real cooking, zero effort. That's the essence. Good ingredients, you cook it yourself, it takes fifteen minutes.
I like that. And tonally, where do you want to sit? Formal and refined, warm and human, playful?
Warm, definitely. Not corporate at all. We want people to feel curious, like they're discovering something. And happy, cooking should feel good, not like a chore.
Agreed. Warm and a little curious. Not witty or jokey though, we've tried that voice and it undercuts the premium positioning.
Noted. And what's the action we want from someone who lands on the site or sees a post? What do they do next?
Order your first box. That's it. Everything should push towards trying one box.
Clear. On platforms, this lives on the website and social media primarily. Any broadcast or TV in the plan?
No TV. Website and social only. Everything in English, Indian English, our audience is fully English-first.
Understood. Now on assets, do you have existing brand guidelines or open files we can work from? Logo source files, anything like that?
We have the logo open files, the AI files from the original designer. There are no real brand guidelines, that's part of why we're here. I'll share the logo files this week.
That's helpful, thank you. On timelines, what are we working towards? Is there a launch date driving this?
We want to go live with the new identity and website before Diwali, so realistically we need everything delivered by the fifteenth of November. That's the hard date.
Fifteenth of November, noted. And who's our main point of contact day to day on your side?
Kabir will be your SPOC, he's our Head of Marketing, he'll handle all the day to day and approvals on creative.
Yes, I'm the main contact. You can reach me directly, I'll set up a shared channel.
And if anything gets stuck or you need a decision fast, escalate to me. I'm the founder, I'll unblock it. Anything budget or scope related comes to me.
Perfect, that's clear. Let me put together a brief from this conversation and share it back for confirmation, then we'll follow with scope and timelines.
Sounds good. Send it across and we'll review by end of week.